bonsoir claude vente maison merci d'être
avec nous y at-il selon vous une
compréhension du contexte français aux
états unis comme semblent le dire
emmanuel macron oui sûrement un certain
degré de d'incompréhension quelquefois
un peu un peu fade
parce que dans le fond on sait très bien
aux états unis quelle est l'origine de
laïcité à la française
la république en france il se trouve que
pour des raisons historiques elle s'est
constituée contre la domination de
l'église catholique
sous l'ancien régime et aujourd'hui les
rapports entre l'état et les religions
sont régies par la loi de 1905 qu'on
appelle souvent la loi de séparation des
églises et de l'état qui d'ailleurs
permet d'avoir des relations apaisées
entre l'état et les relie des religions
on le voit dans les déclarations des
responsables des différentes religions
note française en en france notamment
lors des attentats aux etats unis c'est
très différent il ya jamais eu d lutte
en réalité les pères fondateurs bien sûr
était inspiré les principes des lumières
et la révolution comme ça vient d'être
dit dans votre sujet mais aussi étaient
pour la plupart assez religieux et
aujourd'hui encore le président de la
pression des états unis
lorsqu'il prend ses fonctions jure de
respecter la constitution sur la bible
et dieu est assez souvent évoquée dans
la vie publique aux etats-unis ce qui
n'est pas le cas en france parce que
effectivement les histoires ne sont pas
les mêmes et aux états unis la
séparation est moins importante
cela dit dans les deux pays on respecte
la liberté d'expression on respecte la
liberté pour les citoyens de s'exprimer
où on dira pas toujours les mêmes
conséquences
par exemple aux états unis on permet le
port du voile en france depuis dix ans
le voile est interdit dans les écoles
dans les collèges dans les lycées et
aussi naturellement la couverture du
visage dans les espaces publics
ça paraît naturel dans le contexte
français
ça paraît choquant dans un contexte
américain d'ailleurs l'administration
obama à l'époque elle avait dit haut et
fort c'est pour ça que je crois que le
président de la république est un peu
étonné de l'année des réactions qu'on
entend en amérique du nord aux états
unis mais aussi d'ailleurs chez monsieur
trudeau au canada et ses réactions dans
leur affaiblissement bien entendu la
réaction française aux attentats
puisqu'elle semble dire que ces
attentats ont quand même des causes que
l'on peut expliquer ce n'est pas
uniquement l'extrémisme islamiste qui
est à condamner mais peut-être certains
comportements français alors ça
évidemment c'est assez grave et je crois
que là cela mérite tout une explication
toute une pédagogie à long terme alors
emmanuel macron accordé une interview à
la chaîne de télévision al jazira le
président n'at-il pas sous-estimer comme
blanche maison la nécessité de clarifier
ses propos lors de l'hommage à samuel
petit en tout cas elle est allé au
combat puisque le discours qu'il a
prononcé lors des funérailles nationales
de cervelle pâti du professeur
d'histoire qui a été quand même décapité
devant son collège et bien ont été mal
interprétés en tout cas dans un certain
nombre de pays où la majorité des
habitants et musées pas dans tous mes
nom d'un certain nombre et il a voulu
expliquer il a dit j'ai été mal compris
peut-être mal traduit puisque quelques
fois au lieu de dire terroristes
islamistes ont dit terrorisme islamique
ce qui est tout à fait différent
toujours est il qu'il a fait cette cette
émission d'une heure à djezzy rares et
que cette chaîne
qui la propriété du gouvernement de
qatar est assez observé regarder dans
les états dans les étables musulmans
mais aussi un peu partout dans le monde
par conséquent je ne doute pas que les
grands médias que les chancelleries dans
les différents pays est observé cette
attentivement cette interview
d'autant plus que son texte a été
diffusé ensuite par les services de
l'elysée
alors évidemment il semble bien que les
explications ne suffisent pas puisque
les manifestations continuent
aujourd'hui encore au pakistan au
bangladesh mais il faut continuer
continuer à expliquer que nous n'avons
pas que la france n'a rien contre les
musulmans troisième religion du pays
mais que en effet elle elle ne peut pas
accepter le comportement les terroristes
islamistes et qu'elle luttera de toutes
ses forces contre les terroristes
islamistes d'ailleurs avec l'ensemble
des pays européens avec l'ensemble de
ses alliés est la question que l'on peut
se poser dans ce contexte tout même la
caricature est elle en danger en
définitive
écoutez je ne crois pas et pour répondre
et brièvement à votre question il suffit
de regarder un grand journal du soir
français aujourd'hui monsieur plantu
résume dans une caricature et c'est ça
la vertu des caricatures résume un débat
actuellement importants en france celui
des librairies on voit william
shakespeare lui-même à paris devant une
librairie william shakespeare avec le
rideau baissé et qui devant un bac avec
quelques libre dit clic
or collecte va-t-il quest ix est bon
mais pour être sérieux en effet il faut
bien remarquer que la caricature à une
histoire en france et que cette histoire
s'est développée à partir du xviiie
siècle qu'est la joue un rôle important
dans l'évolution des idées dans la
politique et qu'elle est bien ancrée en
effet dans les institutions françaises
alors une caricature il faut qu'elle
soit libre que l'expression spelling
mais ça ne veut pas dire le fait que
l'on soutienne cette liberté
d'expression ne veut pas dire
que l'on approuve le pointu de la
caricature c'est ce que macro est fait
d'expliquer je suis pas sûr qu'il était
tout à fait compris de tous ces audits
de tous ses auditeurs merci claude
blanchemaison expert en relations
internationales